have you been following by the way sure
okay I've been my dad keeps calling me
every day with updates on this story and
I've become somewhat obsessed with it I
don't know how to pronounce his name the
Carlos danger
Santana not Carlos danger or Santana the
Carlos gossan story the Otto oh yes who
escaped from Chiba Japan yes he did to
this guy what was he in charge of Nissan
yeah he's amazing son cuz my dad keeps
called me he goes he goes yeah he was
the CEO of of Nissen or Nissan Nissan
like it's not I'm not I don't even come
anymore Carlos the song GH OS n gossin
have said that Brazilian name of him he
blasts Japanese justice it was escape or
die in Japan so I guess he was accused
of something he fell like he was not he
said he didn't escape Japan he's he was
seeking justice so this guy he gets
locked up in Japan on financial crimes
they say that he was he was misdirecting
funds from Nissan and declaring him his
income to his own account and so they
arrested him a year of being under house
arrest and trying to figure out how to
get out and he's under crazy
surveillance too he's not saying exactly
how he got out of Japan because I think
he doesn't want to implicate anybody
else right but the story is that some
people got into his house and they put
him in a box full of audio equipment I
think he had a party or was there a band
that played in his house and he goes a
band have a band can't he hired a band
to play in his house yeah and so he gets
into the box with all the audio
equipment and somehow nobody checks the
box on the way out how did he avoid like
in the hotel even how did he get into
cuz they don't the band is probably set
up in a [ __ ] were they in a hotel
suite or were they what everybody brings
a band to their hotel room what was it
like a small private party or was it one
of those things where they were
downstairs playing and he had them play
there and then he [ __ ] left the who
knows maybe he wired some money
someplace else so the band wasn't
she playing for him but it had to be
played all like she made sure the band
was there but nobody knew that he was
the one who hired the band I hope that
they make this into a movie but they
cast it with all women to make it even
better I would love that wouldn't it be
great yeah Melissa McCarthy oh yeah
two guys hurt their backs putting her on
the plane yeah cuz it will work in a
couple ways number one more women in
film number two women millionaires you
know I think it would be better that
Seymour woke yeah yeah
aquafina is over there saying wacky [ __ ]
the whole time I would love it to be
cardi B why he didn't give me the head
of the military reconnaissance right
unit they're like which plane should we
get on and she's like you're like okay
cardi and JLo could play the [ __ ]
Berliner lady perfect Salma Hayek's
trying to fit her titties into the box
does a bass player yeah yeah that's a
good question I guess Anne Hathaway
probably they have Anne Hathaway we play
the bass play have a misunderstanding
because she's like she's like what do
you mean I'm using vagisil and they're
like widens you know I think you said
you saw Ryan I think he's right [ __ ] oh
that's good exhibited a little little
feminine feminine humor and they're like
oh how are you gonna get past that
police chief and you know who the police
chief is Beyonce I'll be really tough to
get through I will watch that
I'll start cat no you have to have a man
ôs does they'll add guys the village
yeah and a man would be the guy that
they fool at the airport yeah and he'd
be my lung going he'd be like I'm gonna
look inside this box right and then
something would happen where they would
go look over here it's a red ball and
then it would roll it and the man would
look at the ball and then they would
roll it pass quietly right we get that
one is flirting with him I get the guy
who played Richard Jewell the guy who
played jeff gillooly's bodyguard you
know ya know you you flicked a pretty
girl flick and I think you're as cute as
a button and I'd like to be your girl
and he's like really then they wheel the
thing right behind him I got it guys you
know who is the part of the Green Beret
team that flirts with the guard
Liz oh is that not great casting good
is that not great time right now she's
so hot right now she's so hard right now
yeah I think I think this could be
really something this is amazing
yeah I can't wait until they incorporate
it into a succession darn no I don't
want it
oh no let y'all start there's nothing to
do with we're gonna put you in a box
[ __ ] I got a drill one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app
[Music]